Speaker 1: Hey, this is going to be a lesson
for some of our younger viewers.
Some of our younger viewers may be totally
unfamiliar with or not super familiar with
a woman named Sarah Palin, who was once the
vice president.
She was almost the vice president of the United
States, were it not for voters choosing Barack
Obama over the late Senator John McCain in
the 2008 presidential election?
Sarah Palin.
Could have been the first female vice president
of the United States, and she would have been
a horrible vice president because she's an
incompetent clown.
Now she has resurfaced and I am going to play
an unbelievable video for you.
She went on Fox News to weigh in on the AOC
controversy.
The AOC controversy is she.
Is for I'm trying to even understand the controversy.
She's for COVID guidelines being followed
and being enacted.
But she went to Florida.
And her partner didn't wear shoes.
I'm sorry he wore flip flops sitting outside
at a restaurant and then she got COVID, and
there's been all sorts of wacky responses
to to her going to Florida and getting COVID.
One of the things that she said, she being
AOC that I think came off as a little bit
pompous to be completely honest, is, she says,
the people the Republicans criticizing her
want to date her.
And this is just so funny.
Sarah Palin, we've covered her for so long
because she ran in 2008.
Sarah Palin loses the ability to communicate
in English.
She has these situations where she's like,
visibly struggling to use language to communicate
anything of meaning.
And it happened again.
And she weirdly says that liberals want to
pound the idea of sex into the minds of people.
See if you can even follow it.
Sarah Palin is saying, Here this is.
This is wild.
Speaker 5: It amazes me, though her and other
liberals, socialists, even their
Speaker 1: ability to say, What socialist
is she talking about
Speaker 5: flat from what the issues truly
are?
And here her obsession with at least suggestions
of always gender and sex.
Even it, you know, I truly believe that there
are enough Americans who get it and understand
what her tactic is, and that is to deflect
from what the real issues are.
But yeah, OK.
Take this issue, though, with her suggestion
of dating.
Speaker 1: And if you're wondering what she's
talking about, everybody is, this is how Sarah
Palin communicates.
It's completely unclear what she's talking
about.
And here we get into pounding.
Speaker 5: And, you know, attraction to someone
and blaming her failures on that.
That obsession with sex.
Look how the liberals Rachel want to pound
that into the public's head.
That pounding advertising who is attracted
to what people do in their own, the privacy
of their own bedrooms, all those things they
have to do with.
Speaker 1: It's really funny to hear Sarah
Palin, who participated in an anti-gay campaign
in 2008 as vice president on religious grounds,
now saying others are talking about what people
are doing in their private bedrooms.
That's really funny.
Speaker 5: Privacy and sex The Liberals, not
the Conservatives, are the one who pound,
pound, pound after that.
And obviously it's a tactic so that she doesn't
have to be held accountable.
Speaker 1: It sounds like they just want to
pound pound, pound about sex and things in
bedrooms.
And this we were used to this Sarah Palin
for a long time.
Complete word salads.
And just as a little history lesson for our
younger viewers, I'm going to play a clip
for you of Sarah Palin.
This is from 2014.
OK.
This is how regularly incoherent she's always
been.
See if you can follow what she's saying here.
Speaker 5: We believe.
Wait, I thought fast food joints.
Don't you guys think that they're like of
the devil or something?
That's what liberals you was in those evil
employees who would dare work at a fast food
joint that you just don't believe in, thought
you wanted to, and I'll send them to purgatory
or something.
Why don't they all go vegan and wages and
picket lines that they're not often discussed
in purgatory, are they?
I don't know.
Why are you even worrying about fast food
wages?
Speaker 1: This has not been edited or doctored
in any way.
This is this is the original thing, she said.
Speaker 5: Well, we believe in America where
minimum wage jobs, they're not lifetime gigs,
they're stepping stone.
Speaker 1: OK, so then then there's me from
from 2014.
That is the Sarah Palin that we have been
used to for a long time, visibly struggling
to use the English language.
And for our younger viewers, you can go to
our YouTube channel and check out some of
our older clips.
It's probably time for her to disappear for
another eight years because these appearances
are not going well.
Make sure that you're following us on Instagram
at David Pakman show we will have these clips
there.
If you have just been listening today, we'll
take a quick break
and be right back.